we are continuing our series crime
without punishment that looks at the
disturbing rise in unsolved murders in
the u.s welcome back to cbs mornings our
investigation uncovered a troubling
racial disparity murder cases are far
less likely to be solved if the victim
is hispanic or black jackson mississippi
has experienced a spike in killings with
more than 150 murders last year and
about four in 10 remain unsolved chief
investigative correspondent jim axelrod
went to jackson to see the toll of
unsolved murders on the relatives of
those who have been killed jim good
morning good morning there are the
numbers and the pain behind the numbers
we traveled to jackson last month to
meet with a small group of mothers who'd
lost their sons
what we found was a community seething
with frustration that more isn't being
done to track down the killers of their
children we also found an overwhelmed
police department that says it can't
possibly keep pace with the violence
everyone in this room
who has had a member
of their family
murdered
raise your hand
when we started calling mothers who'd
lost their children to murder in jackson
mississippi word got around and more
than 30 people arrived for our interview
put your hands up if you feel like
you've had to investigate your own loved
one's death
the pain in this room in jackson was
overwhelming they didn't investigate my
case and more just kept coming
wanting their stories heard even to take
when i talked to them they hung their
farm up in my face willie mack is
himself a former homicide detective at
the jackson police department
what am i saying his daughter was shot
to death in 2017.
hang on how many years were you with
jackson pd
24 years you had 24 years in
and when you call
the detective investigating your
daughter's death
you don't get your calls returned i
don't get no call return
to understand better the depth of their
suffering we sat down with three mothers
from the group my son his name is kellen
thompson jr he was murdered april the
1st 2021.
zachary ryan robinson he was murdered on
april 29th of 2014.
ryan
he was murdered november 26
2020 on thanksgiving
a day after my birthday margie allen
danita williams and lucinda wade
robinson are talking about their sons
all younger than 22
all gunned down in the city of jackson
mississippi population
153 000. has there been any arrest made
in either of these three cases
no
no
not one arrest i showed a picture of my
baby on the side of the road i would
show some information
and i was told to go sign my own crime
go solve your own crime and bring them
the evidence and i would take it to him
in jackson the capital of mississippi
the numbers are stunning
156 homicides last year one of the
highest per capita homicide rates in the
entire country do you feel murder is
being treated
differently
here
murder is at the bottom of the totem
pole it's normal
a young black male is going to die
tomorrow
we have three over the weekend we can't
get to you right now the whole system is
back long
james davis is the chief of the jackson
police department does not solving
homicide cases erode
the trust the community has in the
police department of course we tell
these these citizens the truth
we don't tell them that we can solve a
case without the facts
you know chief davis told us jackson
pd's ability to solve murder cases
depends on processing evidence at the
state crime lab which he says is
overwhelmed i can use more police
officers i can use more homicide
detected but if the state is backed up
the court is backed up we will still
have the same problem by developing
these cases that we're already doing fbi
research suggests homicide detectives
should oversee no more than five cases
per year
jackson pd has eight full-time
detectives that's enough for 40 murder
investigations last year alone they had
nearly four times that number
i don't think any
police department in the nation can say
that they got enough resources jackson
homicide detective sergeant kevin nash
works in an office where each desk is
piled high with files
he knows that means victims relatives
aren't going to like the pace of solving
their loved one's murder sergeant nash i
talked to him and he said
well you know a lot of a lot of y'all
come down here and act like y'all
children are perfect
i said no i said first of all i'm not
acting like my child is perfect but my
child did not deserve to be killed in
the street
but sgt nash says he and his colleagues
are doing the best they can
let me honest with you when your loved
one is killed you can never do enough to
solve that case i call them back when
i'm available it may not be right then
when they want to and remember this was
your child you wanted me to answers too
i will always tell you that the jackson
police department can do a better job
jackson mayor chokwe antar lumumba knows
all too well what unsolved crime can do
to a family my brother was shot in the
head in jackson mississippi so we're no
friend of crime right no one was ever
arrested for that but points out his
police department makes arrests in six
out of ten cases
above the national average i get the
feeling no matter how often you talk
about it the tears don't stop no
no you just lay in bed at night you just
cry all night and you get up and try to
fight more to get justice for your child
it's too much
well it turns out that three weeks after
we visited jackson police made arrests
in the case of margie allen's son a year
and a half after his murder
jackson pd told us it was a long
investigation and they just kept
following the leads now tomorrow
we'll bring you our third story in the
series which takes us to baltimore and
focus on possible solutions to help
police solve
more murder cases
the pain is palpable you can feel it on
the screen just the fact that one mother
would say murder is normal here
it is
among the highest per capita uh homicide
rates in the country
the ballroom where these people spoke
with us
was one of the more
um
uh emotionally riveting powerful places
i've ever been we invited just a few and
they just kept coming
but just the fact that the mother said
that the police said go find go solve it
yourself and bring us the evidence you
know what's wrong with that yeah or mr
willie mack who's a former yeah
detective i get that you're overwhelmed
but as a grieving mother nobody wants to
hear that go solve it yourself so when
we put that question to the detectives i
said look the numbers are what they are
these guidelines say we should have five
cases we have four times that number
we're drinking water from a fire hose
here and we're doing the best we can
feel for those families i do too that
weight it lasts forever on top of it and
based on what you said it's also
overwhelming for the police so it's not
just that they don't want to do it or
that they're callous you're saying it's
more of a problem they don't have enough
resources
so two days of demonstrating problems
tomorrow a solution okay pegged exactly
at that looking forward to that thank
you very much as always we appreciate it